good leg car TV doesn't like that she
lost all her baby weight after welcoming
daughter culture in July yeah and I
think she looks great
I think she looks great yeah she does
but as most moms say it's kind of a
struggle to get your pre-baby body back
after giving birth but kudos to kardia
of course she took to social media of
all places cardi took to Instagram Live
to vent about adjusting to her figures
saying she's too skinny and it's
affecting her mood here's the opposite
of what most people say basically but
yeah but I do think a lot of women like
that curvy feel so I get where she's
come from the answer but here's what
cardi said quote that's been really
depressing me making me sad my weight I
cannot stop losing weight and it's so
crazy because when I first gave birth I
did everything to lose my baby weight
but now I can't gain weight because I
have a terrible appetite
I can literally go 24 hours without
eating okay I am obsessed with cardi for
this exact reason she always keeps it
real sharing authentic I love that she's
opening up about this I hate that she
feels depressed about it yeah but I was
naughty honesty exactly a lot of moms go
through that postpartum depression and
struggle to even find time to eat and
lose that baby weight right and I know
that her insecurity is also stemmed from
being thin in high school she actually
said this during the rant yeah she said
she used to hate it yeah so I mean how
do you think she looked on the carpet
cuz you were just with her I thought she
looked great of course to each its own
yeah I was just with cardi literally on
Wednesday she was glowing she looked
fantastic she seemed happy healthy I
think she looked amazing and that's all
you could want of course we want to keep
that conversation going first of all
what are your body insecurities that you
struggle with we all have them yeah yeah
and do you guys think that cardis new
weight looks good on her let us know
well like you said beware with car
dealer this week and while her body is
going through changes there's one thing
that hasn't changed since she became a
mom about four months ago take a look I
don't feel like I got to change my style
because I had
a baby I feel like the only time I
should change my style is if I have my
baby on me like no I'm not I don't want
to wear them thong and walk around my
baby party that's the time bottle for
like I gotta change like I love that so
she's not changing her style really at
all we also respect yeah I respect it
but you know what cardi has a really
good point I know she wants the game
back that way but she's look used to
seeing herself a lot more curvy yeah I
kind of get how anytime your body change
you're gonna have insecurities of course
we know there are other stars that have
faced the same body insecurities since
giving birth we have Blake Lively Pete
Egan Kylie Jenner Kim Kardashian's all
been so open about it though exactly
I love that like nothing in my closet
fits me but you're looking like really
skinny thank you I'm just feeling a
little insecure I feel like my hips have
just spread of no return okay so moving
back to cardi B and what we talked to
her about this week she also mentioned
why she doesn't want to show culture to
the world yet take a look why aren't you
sharing her yet I'm scared to share it
to the world
you know I'm scared there's so many
people out there but sometimes I just
want to show people how beautiful and
how precious she is she's so precious
seriously now Katie
I completely understand where cardi is
coming from the Internet can be so
brutal especially with young children I
mean I understand where cardies coming
from to have that privacy for her baby I
could not agree more she wants to
protect her she says that she's the most
precious thing in her world she calls
her for a little ducky which is
something cutest thing um what do you
guys make of this though about moms not
wanting to share their kids on social
media of course we want to keep this
conversation going all across social I'm
at Kourtney underscore tezo know and I'm
Kati underscore crass
I need to talk all things cardi well
until next time of course we've got you
covered for your pop culture pigs hi
guys
you